if an audience member comes to you with
for example does that not mean that you
should at least have thought about the
definition of all the words in your
because if someone asks a question like
I didn't understand the word flight I'll
give you an example I'll give you a very
good example which is often brought up
and again it's brought up by devil's
advocates Xtreme devil's advocate who
says I'm gonna make them fall and so
they ask this question just to make you
you know go blush or go red or whatever
and they say well you said object is
that which has shape what do you mean by
shape that's the question they ask and
and I have very good answers for that I
think you know that and I'm not gonna
define shape because the word shape does
not need to be defined we don't need to
know what shape is not not in any
scientific or SuperDuper astrophysicists
way let me tell you why where we have a
competition for criteria so one guy says
look you know you ask well what a shape
but what is an object to you and he says
well an object is that which I can see
the other guy says no it's that which I
can touch the other guy says no it's
it's a volume the other guy says no it's
mass the other guy says no it's that
which can move so they have all these
criteria and I'm saying no and objects
that which has shape now do we all
understand every one of those words we
don't need to we in general the word the
definition of ordinary speech is
sufficient I don't need to know exactly
what he meant by motion I just need to
know that motion is different than shape
and shape is different and volume and
volume is different than mass as long
and touch and see as long as we have a
distinction we have a competition
between these words I'm saying look your
definition based on C touch mass volume
whatever cannot compete against my
definition of shape and the guy says so
the debate is whether shape is a better
criterion for the purposes of physics
than motion or
then volume or mass or whatever not not
to harp on well what did you mean by
shake well don't you know what cheap is
and that's where I use the other example
and I'm saying we'll go to a
kindergarten and you'll find these three
and four-year-olds these toddlers there
and show more Cube and show a ball you
know a round rounded tube one of them is
you just take two of his toys one is a
ball shape the other ones are a cubic
shape they're both the same color
there's everything is the same except
one has a different shape than the other
and you say what is the difference
between these two and he said well the
shape well now the kid didn't go to the
other ten ones in your right hand
yeah the kid didn't go to college and he
can say well yeah the only thing I see
different is the shape and that's the
word what we call shape the one that a
cube is different than a than a ball you
know we don't need to have a high level
definition of shape we just need to use
shape as a criteria to oppose what the
mathematicians use as as criteria which
is see touch see and touch require
another object so it's a redundant
definition it's a synonym in a sense
that you need an object to define an
object its circular you need you know
the object that's seeing it's also
subjective when you're going pass
through that but let's go deep on that
why can't you define an object as that
which I can touch because that means you
need something another object to do the
touch and what's the problem well
because you're trying to define the word
object you're saying well let me let me
let me run a test for you I'm gonna
bring an object to touch your object and
that's what I'm gonna call an object the
one that I can touch so that's
essentially what you're saying so you're
introducing another object ginder
tacitly implicitly just to do the
touching to see that's what that's one
issue but the other issue is that it's
subjective because now officially in the
case of scene you require well what did
you see I didn't see the object oh you
didn't see the other so it's not an
oddity the moon I'm blind you know I'm a
blind night I can't see the moon so it's
not an object so it's it's subjective oh
I I haven't land
the mood so I haven't touched the moon
so it's not an object until I land on it
you know that kind of thing are you
essentially saying it compels you to run
a test and the question is can you run a
test with the object on the other side
of the universe can you see it can you
land on it if you can't then it's not an
object the star that's on the other side
of the universe the word star is not an
object consensual issue it is but what
do I get a definition for the purposes
of physics how do you know it's
touchable you never had some oh yeah and
again but again it requires first an
object's and second is subject and the
third requires an experiment so it means
that if there's only hires an assumption
but look look if there's a single object
in the whole universe there's no other
option right you have a cube there is
that cube an object according to our
definition oh it's a cube because it's
an object because it has shape whereas
you say well I need another object to
touch it to find out if it's an
opportunity that's where we have a
problem with the touchable definition
that would be impossible to have one
object in the universe Yeah right yeah
one end and that's exactly how we have
to treat the word object as if the table
were the only object in the universe so
you point to the table say I'm not the
second object but I'm God I don't have a
spirit and I'd point to the table and
say table and the only thing the et the
guy who is under trying to understand my
language sees or visualizes or has as an
object there is the table that's the way
we should treat it when we introduce an
object in physics